la séance est ouverte monsieur le
premier ministre
madame et messieurs les ministres
mesdames messieurs les députés chers
collègues nous réunissons aujourd'hui
dans un contexte singulier puisque notre
pays vit une crise sanitaire d'une
ampleur exceptionnelle dont les
répercussions humaines civique
économiques et sociales sont encore
difficiles à mesurer
permettez moi au nom de la
représentation nationale d' exprimer
notre compassion pour les familles qui
connaissent le deuil pour les malades
qui souffrent de l'épidémie et notre
profonde reconnaissance pour tous ceux
qui oeuvrent au quotidien
je pense aux soignants et aux
professionnels de santé de secours mais
aussi à tous les fonctionnaires et
citoyens mobilisés et engagé qui
assistent souvent dans l'inquiétude et
parfois dans la détresse
nos compatriotes en souffrance j'appelle
tous nos concitoyens à respecter
strictement les recommandations qui nous
sont données pour nous protéger
collectivement et individuellement
j'adresse en votre nom une pensée
particulière aux collègues personnel et
collaborateurs de notre assemblée
aujourd'hui convalescent et leur
souhaite de se rétablir dans les
meilleurs conditions et les délais les
plus brefs avec le double devoir de
respecter ici scrupuleusement les
consignes des autorités scientifiques et
sanitaires et de faire vivre notre
démocratie nous sommes réunis dans un
format réduit en nombre de participants
pour contrôler l'action du gouvernement
et des pouvoirs publics
je salue nos collègues qui suivent nos
travaux à distance d après cette séance
la commission concernée par le premier
des textes urgent transmis par le
gouvernement commencera son travail ses
textes
ont pour vocation d'aider concrètement
nos compatriotes face aux difficultés de
toutes sortes
puis viendra le débat dans l'hémicycle
aujourd'hui sur le projet de loi de
finances rectificative et demain sur les
projets de lois portant sur les mesures
d'urgence à prendre sur l'organisation
des élections municipales et sur les
enjeux économiques et sociaux je tiens à
remercier les présidents de tous les
groupes politiques
l'ensemble des députés également nos
collègues non inscrits qui ont tous
consentie avec un sens élevé des
responsabilités pour notre république
que se tienne nos travaux dans des
modalités inhabituel lié aux
circonstances exceptionnelles que
connaît notre pays
plus que jamais l'assemblée nationale et
le coeur battant de notre république et
de notre démocratie dont nous
garantissons ensemble ici les valeurs et
les principes l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions au gouvernement
la conférence des présidents a décidé
d'une organisation spécifique de notre
séance de questions
les membres du gouvernement sont
présents en nombre restreint de plus il
a été demandé de limiter à chaque groupe
pour chaque groupe le nombre de ses
représentants
outre le président du groupe ou son
délégué participer seul à cette séance
les auteurs des questions je vous
rappelle que deux questions seront
posées par chaque groupe et une par un
député non inscrit
afin de favoriser la cohérence du débat
les questions relatives aux mêmes thèmes
ont été regroupés les temps de parole
sont les temps habituel deux minutes par
question et autant par raiponce répliqué
contre réplique éventuellement comprise
j'invite les orateurs à ne pas poser les
mains sur le flexible du micro celui ci
sera nettoyée après chaque usage par un
huissier
par ailleurs chaque micro n'aura que
l'utilisateur
cours de cette séance je vous invite à
rester à la même place toute la séance
naturellement il conviendra de respecter
des mesures barrières que nous
connaissons tous en particulier les
entrées des sorties devront être
échelonné je vous indique enfin que
l'hémicycle a été désinfecté sera
nettoyée avant et après chaque séance je
vous remercie de votre compréhension et
de votre concours
compte tenu de ces circonstances très
exceptionnelles
nous commençons notre séance par des
questions portant sur la crise du que
vides 19 en général et notamment le
thème de la santé
la parole est à monsieur damien abad
président du groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
mais ces dames et messieurs les
ministres le mot d'union nationale
claque comme un drapeau comme celui qui
arborait ce matin à l'assemblée de notre
astre à l'entrée de notre assemblée
comme celui qui flotte dans chacune de
nos communes comme celui qui anime le
coeur des français dans ces temps
troublés confiné mais pas résignés les
français luttent en restant chez eux
c'est ce même esprit de responsabilité
et ce même sens du devoir qui doit nous
animer nous députés de la nation et
porte drapeau de cette france
hospitalière qui méritent notre
reconnaissance
notre soutien et notre mobilisation
pleine et entière si nous sommes là
aujourd'hui c'est pour sauver des vies
et sauver des emplois
sauver des vies monsieur le premier
ministre c'est relever le défi sanitaire
d'une france médicale en manque de
moyens cette france médicales elles
manquent de masques de lits de
réanimation de médicaments elle manque
d'explications sur les retards de
livraison
elle manque de vérité faire la vérité
sur ces éléments comme le fait très bien
chaque jour le directeur général ou le
ministre de la santé sur la situation
sanitaire notre pays ce n'est pas
polémiquer notre devoir de gouvernants
et d'être transparent ainsi le
gouvernement pourrait-il envisagée
un point journalier du haut
fonctionnaire de défense du ministère de
l'intérieur ou du ministre lui-même en
lien avec 927 préfet afin de présenter
chaque jour un état des lieux précis de
la production de l'approvisionnement et
de la livraison du matériel médical et
notamment des masques
ces masques qui manque également à nos
policiers
nos pompiers nos services d'aidé à
domicile ou encore dans nos ehpad
responsabilités et vérité voilà ce que
nous devons aux français monsieur le
premier ministre devant une épidémie
d'une telle ampleur il n'y a pas
seulement une majorité et une opposition
il ya surtout une assemblée nationale
unie et rassemblée
tout simplement parce que face aux
coronavirus nous ne gagnerons que
collectivement
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
président abbas je voudrais m'inscrire
dans l'esprit et dans le sens de la
question que vous avez posé dans
l'esprit qui fait appel à l'unité
nationale à la responsabilité à l'idée
simple que confronté à une crise d'une
ampleur inégalée crise sanitaire d'une
ampleur inégalée
mais tout indique que les conséquences
de cette crise sanitaire inégalée seront
économique financière sociale
il nous appartient à nous tous quels que
soient nos responsabilités quelles que
soient nos convictions et nous savons
qu'elles peuvent diverger de nous
rassembler dans l'idée simple que c'est
l'intérêt général et l'intérêt supérieur
du pays
le service de nos concitoyens qu'il faut
d'abord garantir et assurer je m'inscris
donc tout à fait dans la logique que
vous venez d'évoquer vous nous invitez
le gouvernement est en vérité tout
autorités administratives et politiques
un exercice et un effort à une
discipline
responsabilité et de vérité et de
transparence
là encore monsieur le président à battre
je m'inscris dans cette logique
c'est ce qui conduit vous le savez le
directeur général de la santé et le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire à
s'exprimer quotidiennement pour faire le
point sur la situation sanitaire
le nombre de malades le nombre de décès
l'évolution des choses
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire
dans dans tout l'ensemble de ce que cela
peut vouloir dire c'est la raison pour
laquelle aussi monsieur le président
abbas nous avons décidé de compléter le
dispositif qui reposait sur une cellule
interministérielle de crise gérée au
ministère des solidarités la santé qui
pilotait l'ensemble de la réponse
sanitaire
nous avons décidé de faire en sorte que
la totalité du sanitaire soit organisée
au ministère de la santé mais que en
complément de cette date force
interministériel comme on l'appelle la
cellule interministérielle de crise où
est également activé à beauvau pour que
sur tous les aspects non sanitaires il
puisse y avoir la communication que
d'une certaine façon vous appelez de vos
voeux
elle sera réalisée tous les soirs ou
même moment que celle qui intervient par
le directeur général de la santé le
directeur général de la sécurité civile
pourra s'exprimer sur les remontées dans
les pratiques des préfectures
la situation sur le terrain tous les
aspects non sanitaires qui entrent en
ligne de compte dans la crise que nous
devons gérer sur la question de la
mobilisation de notre système de soin
vous avez parlé du système hospitalier
mais je sais que vous aviez évidemment à
l'esprit l'ensemble du système de soins
car si les hospitaliers sont en première
ligne aujourd'hui le système libéral la
médecine de ville la médecine de
campagne sont évidemment directement
concernés la mobilisation de l'ensemble
de notre système de santé et complète la
stratégie que nous avons suivi elle a
été présentée de façon très simple et
très clair par le ministre des
solidarités de la santé c'est cette
stratégie qui consiste à alice et le pic
épidémique a essayé de faire en sorte
d'aplatir au maximum la courbe pour
faire en sorte que
le pic ne soit jamais trop au dessus de
la capacité totale que nous pouvons
avoir pour traiter les cas les plus
sévères de cette maladie pour cela nous
avons essayé d'abord d'augmenter la
capacité à accueillir les cas les plus
sévères
c'est à dire monter notre limite d'une
certaine façon c'est ce qui a été fait à
la fois par l'équipement de nouveaux
lits par la transformation de lits en
lits de réanimation ou de soins
intensifs et par là des progrès par la
déprogrammation pardon des opérations
qui pouvaient conduire après l'opération
à la salle de réanimation lille
réanimation aux lits de soins intensifs
ces opérations ont permis d'augmenter la
capacité d'accueil dans les hôpitaux
français
la deuxième étape c'est évidemment de
faire en sorte
lorsqu'il ya des places disponibles
ailleurs sur le territoire que dans des
zones qui sont extrêmement sollicités de
pouvoir déplacer les malades dans des
conditions de sûreté
évidemment garantie c'est ce que nous
avons commencé à faire avec
l'utilisation des forces armées vous le
savez pour faire en sorte que des
malades qui étaient hospitalisées dans
le grand-est puisse être transféré à
toulon c'est ce qui est intervenue
depuis dans le courant de la semaine
et puis il ya la question que vous
évoquez des masques sur laquelle je sais
que j'aurai l'occasion de revenir ce que
je ne veux pas
parlez trop longtemps mais je sais que
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir ce matin
là aussi vous dire que notre objectif
c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte
d'abord que cette ressource rare soit
bien utilisé ce qui n'est pas facile
c'est à dire de fixer une doctrine est
d'essayer de faire en sorte que chacun
respecte de faire en sorte que les
sources d'approvisionnement de ces
masques soit garanti sources nationales
sources internationales pendant très
longtemps nous nous sommes reposés sur
des approvisionnements qui vit et qui
venaient principalement de chine
la chine a utilisé beaucoup ses sources
d'approvisionnement et donc il y a de ce
point de vue quelque chose à corriger
mais nous sommes en train de garantir la
distribution dans les officines et dans
les hôpitaux et dans les ehpad des
masques disponibles et nécessaires je
sais que le ministre des solidarités de
la santé pourra y revenir que je veux
dire sans rentrer dans le détail mais je
leur revient j'y reviendrai dans
quelques instants
c'est que la mobilisation est complète
la difficulté est considérable car le
nombre de cas sévères est important et
c'est ce nombre de cas sévères qui est
préoccupant vous le savez dans plus de
80% des cas la maladie le comique 19 se
déclare sous des formes bénignes
désagréable mais bennie ce qui est
préoccupant c'est le nombre de cas
sévères sur la totalité des cas de
l'ordre
on le dit parfois de 10% et ces cas
sévères quand ils sont véritablement des
cas sévères nécessite souvent une
hospitalisation et peuvent aller jusqu à
des salles de réanimation des lits de
réanimation et c'est évidemment là
qu'est le sujet et c'est pour ça vous
l'avez dit il nous faut le dire le
redire le répéter que les mesures de
confinement qui ont été décidées et que
les gestes barrière qui sont rappelés de
façon systématique sont les éléments les
plus efficaces pour ralentir la
circulation de virus et donc limiter au
maximum le nombre de cas sévères que
j'évoquais merci monsieur le premier
ministre la parole et à madame nathalie
et limaces pour le groupe wendel
merci ma question s'adresse au ministre
chargé de la ville et du logement
l'épidémie à laquelle notre pays est
confronté a conduit le gouvernement à
réagir de manière forte et courageuse en
prenant des mesures de confinement pour
freiner la propagation du virus
en cet instant j'ai une pensée
particulière pour nos soignants
qui se battent sans relâche pour nos
aînés pour les malades et pour tous ceux
dont le travail est impacté mais je
pense également aux personnes vivant
sans domicile fixe qui vont subir
l'épidémie de plein fouet
250000 dont 3500 sdf à paris ce sont des
personnes déjà malades avec des haches
qu'il faut majorer et pour qui les
mesures de confinement seront
particulièrement compliqué à mettre en
place tout comme les gestes barrière les
accueils de jour sont contraints de
fermer alors que les centres
d'hébergement sont déjà à saturation
le matériel de protection manque malgré
le risque accru de contamination et les
bénévoles et personnels des associations
ne peuvent en l'état
bénéficiez des systèmes de garde
d'enfants si certaines initiatives de
collectivités locales sont utiles et je
pense à la mise en place de à la mise à
disposition de gymnase c'est évidemment
insuffisant tant en termes d'efficacité
que d'humanité
l'enjeu ici est double il s'agit de
santé et de salubrité publique
dans ce contexte particulièrement tendu
je salue le travail formidable des
bénévoles qui font face à de grandes
difficultés pour maintenir les activités
de première ligne distribution
alimentaire maraude par manque de
personnel disponible
monsieur le ministre il est de notre
devoir de protéger nos concitoyens et il
est de notre responsabilité de ne
laisser personne sur le bord de la route
pouvez vous nous indiquer quelles
mesures d'urgence seront décidées afin
de maintenir l'assistance aux plus
vulnérables et quelles solutions
pourront être mises en place
vite pour accompagner les bénévoles de
ces associations maillon essentiel de
notre chaîne de solidarité
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est un monsieur julien de
normandie ministre chargé de la ville et
du logement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs des députés madame la députée
où il est de notre devoir de protéger
les plus fragiles où il est de notre
responsabilité de mettre en oeuvre tout
ce qui doit être fait pour pouvoir
protéger celles et ceux qui notamment
sont à la rue je voudrais le dire ici je
voudrais vous affirmer que la
mobilisation de mon ministère de
l'administration qui fait un travail
remarquable
des collectivités mais aussi des
associations que je salue elle est
totale cette mobilisation elle est
totale pour d'abord mettre à l'abri
celles et ceux qui vivent encore dehors
la situation est évidemment compliqué
parce que cette mise à l'abri elle
nécessite des dispositifs particuliers
on privilégie notamment les chambres
individuelles les hôtels on travaille
beaucoup avec ces derniers pour pouvoir
libérer un maximum de chambre les
premières ouvertes dès hier soir avant
la fin de la semaine à paris
170 places seront ouvertes et nous
allons continuer ainsi jour après jour
la deuxième priorité c'est de protéger
les sans abri qui malheureusement aurait
été infestés par le cos vide 19 mai ne
nécessiterait pas d'aller à l'hôpital
parce que les symptômes ne serait pas
grave pour ces personnes-là
nous ouvrons d'ores et déjà des centres
dédiés 150 places ouvriront à paris
avant la fin de la semaine et dans ses
environs et 80 sites ont été identifiés
partout sur le territoire national pour
ce faire tout cela nécessite des moyens
c'est une enveloppe de 50 millions
d'euros qui est d'ores et déjà déployés
et s'il faut aller plus loin nous irons
plus loin et enfin tout cela nécessite
une parfaite organisation
c'est ce que nous faisons avec les
associations dont je veux vraiment
saluer le courage la sérénité le
professionnalisme ces associations qui
font face à des défis notamment de
personnel que nous accompagnons dans le
cadre d'un pilotage et d'une
organisation dédiée que nous avons mises
en place merci pour votre mobilisation
et il nous faut continuer la solidarité
ne doit pas être une victime du coc vite
19 jamais merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est à madame valérie rabault
président du groupe socialiste et
apparentés président je vous remercie
je remercie le gouvernement d'avoir pris
la décision courageuse du confinement
est bien entendu pourrait compter sur
notre soutien en cette unité que nous
appelons de nos voeux
la question de cette crise sanitaire
pause il ya évidemment plusieurs
questions je vais en retenir 3 la
première porte sur les masses que vous
l'avez dit monsieur premier ministre
aujourd'hui à plusieurs millions de
français qui continuent à travailler que
ce soit des caissiers des postiers des
sapeurs-pompiers bien sûr tous les
personnels médicaux et qui n'ont pas de
masque qui partent au travail avec l'
angoisse pour eux mêmes et pour leurs
familles alors monsieur le premier
ministre croit qu'il est très important
que vous puissiez nous donner les pas de
la production de masques vous avez pris
un décret le 13 mars avec des
réquisitions sur les stocks
moi je souhaiterais que ce décret puisse
être complétée avec une réquisition sur
les usines de production même celles qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de produire des
masses mais qui auraient des savoir
faire pour le mettre en oeuvre
deuxième question monsieur le premier
ministre on voit que les pays qui pour
l'heure on le peut être le plus réussi à
endiguer cette épidémie sont ceux qui
ont déployé de manière massive les tests
sur leur territoire national
je souhaiterais que vous puissiez nous
repréciser la doctrine du gouvernement
et vu l'augmentation de l'épidémie est
ce que vous pourriez nous dire si oui ou
non il sera possible d'augmenter le
nombre de tests pour pouvoir
circonscrire par endroits l'épidémie
enfin dernière question qui est
économique j'entends bien que c'est pas
là l'objectif numéro un aujourd'hui
puisqu'il faut sauver des vies mais je
voudrais quand même attirer votre
attention monsieur le premier ministre
vous avez proposé un report de
cotisations de 2 mois pour les
restaurateurs les indépendants tous ceux
qui n'ont plus d'activité aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont plus de
rentrées d'argent
je souhaiterais que ce report puis s'est
transformé en annulation sûr de moi
parce que demander à ces indépendants de
payer des cotisations de l'argent qu'ils
n'auront pas me paraît extrêmement
difficile je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente la parole est
à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la
présidente les masques les tests et le
report de cotisations et de fiscalité
sur les masques vous l'avez dit j'ai
commencé à répondre à monsieur le
président à bad et je sais que le
ministre olivier ferrand complétera ma
réponse sur les basques nous avons pris
en effet un décret de réquisition il
existe quatre producteurs de basques en
france ce qui nous place pardon c'est
une incidente dans une situation qui est
plutôt plus favorable qu'un certain
nombre de nos voisins européens qui eux
n'ont pas de producteur de masque chez
eux
nous avons réquisitionné nous avons pris
la décision de réquisitionner la
totalité de la production et des stocks
ce faisant nous avons accru le nombre de
masques que nous dont nous disposons en
stock
il y avait des stops d'état il avait
commencé à être utilisé donc le stock
avait décru pour descendre jusqu'à un
peu plus de près de 90 millions 89
millions il est remonté
lorsque nous avons procédé aux
réquisitions des stocks et nous sommes
aujourd'hui au dessus des 100 millions
mais la situation change en tous les
jours et la parole que nous prononçons
étant souvent fixés ça donne
l'impression d' incohérences jeu ce que
je veux dire c'est que nous avons
remonté après les réquisitions
nous procédons aux distributions c'est
distribution de masques elle s'effectue
selon une doctrine que je n'ai pas fixé
moi même c'est évidemment les autorités
de santé qui compte tenu de la
disponibilité
compte tenu de la demande détermine la
doctrine des usages j'ai compris de ce
que disent les autorités de santé que le
port du masque en population générale
n'était pas recommandé il n'est pas
recommandé d'abord parce que l'utilité
du port du masque en population générale
autrement dit lorsqu'on se promène dans
la rue lorsque on respecte les gestes
barrière lorsqu'on respecte les
distances de sécurité
il n'est pas recommandé car il est
inutile et qu'il prive ceux qui ont
besoin des masques parce que leurs
activités les places dans des situations
qui ne sont pas celles de la population
générale
les soignants bien entendu tous ceux qui
sont directement au contact des malades
ou les malades eux mêmes déclaré a faim
de limiter la propagation du virus qu'il
fallait donc réserver les masques
disponibles à ces catégories de
population c'est ce que j'appelle la
doctrine c'est important de l'expliquer
c'est important de la faire comprendre
et c'est important de la respecter car
je suis bien sûr madame la présidente
que comme moi vous avez vu certains de
nos concitoyens inquiet et je ne leur
jette très certainement pas la pierre
inquiet porter des masques alors même
qu'il n'était pas au contact des malades
alors même qu'il n'était pas malade et
qui n'étaient pas personnel soignant
lorsque l'on fait ça c'est à peu près le
seul selon genre de comportement qui
rend plus difficile
l'affectation des moyens nécessaires à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
nous sommes en train de procéder à ces
opérations de distribution des stocks de
masques vers les hôpitaux vers les ehpad
vers les pharmacies d'officine de façon
à ce que les médecins libéraux
les infirmières l'ensemble de ceux qui
ont vocation à disposer de célas puisse
y avoir accès ce sont des opérations
techniquement compliqué techniquement
compliqué d'abord parce que la
réquisition a rendu plus compliquée la
logistique je passe sur les questions
techniques mais aussi parce que nous
assistons
ils ne sont pas majoritaires
heureusement mais les ignorer ce serait
ignorer la réalité
nous assistons parfois à des
comportements qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
disparition de stocks de masques dans
certains hôpitaux disparition de
certains boss de stocks de masques dans
des endroits où ils étaient stockés ou
en réalité une disparaissent pas tout
seuls et ils font parfois l'objet d'un
vol de précaution et parfois l'objet de
trafics
nous le savons d'un marché noir ces
comportements sont inacceptables
ils mettent en danger les soignants et
illumine la cohérence et la confiance
nationale
il faut donc évidemment les réprimer et
croyez moi ces comportements seront
réprimés les tests
nous avons là aussi est d'abord une
doctrine de tests qui a consisté dans la
phase 1 de l'épidémie lorsque nous
voulons éviter son introduction sur le
territoire a testé beaucoup et c'est est
cette logique de tests de important
numériquement au début de l'épidémie a
permis de circonscrire assez
efficacement les première apparition du
virus ce qui nous a donné du temps du
temps nécessaire c'est ce qui s'est
passé dans les alpes c'est ce qui s'est
passé au début de l'apparition d'un
cluster en bretagne dans le morbihan je
crois c'est ce qui nous a permis de
contenir au tout début
l'apparition de l'épi les jours d'hui la
doctrine de tests c'est que nous testons
les personnes qui présentent des
symptômes ducobu de 19 et qui sont
hospitalisés sont évidemment testé nous
testons les personnels soignants qui
présentent des symptômes
nous testons les personnes qui
présenteraient des symptômes les deux
premières personnes qui présentent des
symptômes dans un établissement type
ehpad de façon à pouvoir prendre très
rapidement des dispositions de
confinement lorsque c'est nécessaire
bref la doctrine d'utilisation des tests
au stade iii a forcément évolué il ne
servirait à rien aujourd'hui de tester
massivement tout le monde
préventivement ou en fonction des
symptômes car nous embolie serions les
capacités d'analysé et du coup nous
n'aurions pas les réponses suffisamment
rapide la housse est absolument
nécessaire
un dernier mot sur les tests puisque
vous me posez la question
nous avons mis au point très rapidement
un test je le dis parce que ça n'est pas
le cas partout
nous avons mis au point très rapidement
un certain nombre de tests
pour procéder à ces tests
il faut des réactifs il faut une chaîne
logistique qui fonctionne bien il faut
que nous puissions continuer à produire
ce qui nous permet d'analyser ces tests
et nous savons qu'avec le confinement et
c'est bien naturel un certain nombre de
lignes logistiques sont interrompus ou
rendue plus délicate
c'est une des raisons est un des enjeux
qui va être le nôtre dans les jours et
les semaines qui viennent faire en sorte
que les consignes de confinement soit
respecté strictement respecter et faire
également en sorte que l'activité
nécessaires aux pays qui n'est pas
simplement l'activité stratégique entre
guillemets qui est nécessaire au pays
puisse se poursuivre lorsqu'une chaîne
logistique s'interrompt je prends un
exemple qui peut sembler triviale mais
qui est important lorsqu'une usine qui
produit 2 du papier ou du carton d
emballage s'arrête on se dit l'emballage
c'est pas stratégique pour le pays
sauf que lorsque vous n'avez plus cette
usine d'emballage vous pouvez vous
trouver dans une situation où vous
n'allez pas pouvoir préparer la façon
dont tu l'agroalimentaire les masques ou
les médicaments sont distribués et vous
retrouvez donc dans une situation
matérielle qui est extrêmement
dangereuse autrement dit nous devons
conserver dans le pays même en période
de confinement le minimum d'activités
économiques nécessaires à la vie du pays
est nécessaire à la préparation durban
ce qui me permet et nous savons que des
questions telles que celles ci ont pu
affecter récemment mais je pense que le
problème a été réglé par semaine je suis
sûr que problème a été réglé parce qu'il
a été identifié d'une usine de
production un centre de production de
des réactifs utiles à la réalisation de
ces tests la dernière question que vous
me posez même la présidente est relatif
à l'économie aux mesures que nous allons
mettre en oeuvre vous savez
vous avez vu que nous allions présenté
cet après midi au sénat et demain des
mesures d'urgence elles sont massives
vous nous demander d'aller au delà la
question se posera forcément
commençons par nous concentrer sur ce
que nous proposons maintenant qui est
massif et qui doit permettre à chaque
entreprise de tenir pendant cette
période de déstabilisation complète de
façon à pouvoir repartir ensuite c'est
la logique qui nous anime
elle va nécessiter beaucoup de moyens
elle va nécessiter beaucoup d'engagement
de la part de l'état bien entendu c'est
à dire de nous tous
pas de tous dans cet hémicycle nous tous
la nation entière
elle m'a demandé beaucoup d'engagement
de la part des régions qui vont nous
accompagner et qu'ils l'ont dit beaucoup
d'engagement de la part des
organisations syndicales et patronales
que nous avons consultés et qui se sont
elles mêmes engagées sur ce point la
situation va être tendu elle va être
difficile mais j'ai bon espoir qu'avec
la mobilisation générale nous puissions
y faire face merci monsieur le premier
ministre
la parole est à monsieur christophe
naegelen au logo plus d agir merci
monsieur le président parmi les nombreux
obstacles auxquels font face les
professionnels de santé qui luttent
chaque jour et à tout instant contre
l'épidémie qui paralyse notre pays et
qui est l'une des plus inquiétantes que
le monde ait connu ces dernières années
nous ne pouvons que déplorer le manque
chronique d'équipement et plus
particulièrement le manque de masques de
protection
la politique de réquisition est à
parfaire
et ce urgemment et pour cela il est
nécessaire de simplifier les conditions
d'un port et notamment pour ne prendre
en compte que les normes sanitaires
de plus il n'est pas tolérable de mettre
en place une priorisation de
l'importance de chacun des acteurs
chaque maillon est essentiel qu'il
s'agisse du milieu hospitalier ou la
médecine de ville aussi bien que des à
domicile des sages-femmes les aides
soignants dans les ehpad les
ambulanciers les pompiers les forces de
l'ordre mènent ou caissiers chacun
effectue un travail essentiel au
détriment de leur santé et celle de
leurs proches
dans cet état d'urgence sanitaire l'état
leur doit à tous
reconnaissance et protection
d'ailleurs certains spécialistes du
domaine médical tels que les dentistes
recommande d'arrêter les soins faute
d'équipements de protection individuelle
on peut prendre aussi l'exemple de ce
cabinet dentaire de ce cabinet
d'infirmières libérales dans les vosges
ou trois infirmières qui devait se voir
livrer 50 masques chacune pour assurer
leur sécurité et celle de leur passion
et qui se retrouve finalement avec 50
masques pour 3 monsieur le ministre vous
avez promis à tous ces professionnels de
les protéger
et malheureusement du fait du manque
d'équipements ce n'est pas le cas
actuellement
monsieur le ministre comptez vous
simplifier et accélérer les procédures
d'importation et comment allez-vous
mettre en place une politique de
distribution plus efficace et plus
égalitaire
afin de protéger les professionnels et
de protéger les français
merci chers collègues la parole à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé mais monsieur
le député monsieur le député vous
m'interrogez sur les matériels de
protection à destination des personnes
qui prennent soin de nous qui soigne nos
malades
ces personnes pour qui j'ai évidemment
une pensée très forte ce matin à l'heure
alors de vous répondre je vous donner
des chiffres
monsieur le député pour que chacun
puisse se rendre compte des
distributions qui sont en cours
nous avons des stocks et à ma demande 25
millions de masques chirurgicaux au
début du mois de mars a fait qu'une
réquisition de l'ensemble des stocks et
des capacités de production de notre
pays
le 3 mars nous sommes le seul pays à
avoir réalisé ce qu'on appelle un
monitoring complet des stocks des
capacités de production et des besoins
nous disposions alors et je les dis tout
de suite d'un stock d'état d'environ 150
millions de masques chirurgicaux et
aucun stock d'état de masques ffp2 il
avait été en effet décidé suite aux
crises sanitaires précédentes et je
remonte en cela pour cela à 2011 et 2013
qu'il n'y avait plus lieu de conserver
des stocks massives de masques dans le
territoire considérant que les usines de
production était capable d'être actif
très rapidement notamment en chine
seulement voilà la crise sanitaire elle
a commencé par toucher la chine et donc
les usines chinoises ont été à l'arrêt
et les pays européens se sont trouvés en
difficulté donc je vous le dis et je le
dis avec force
les masques ffp2 les masques
chirurgicaux sont des biens précieux
indispensable vitaux que nous devons
utiliser avec la plus grande parcimonie
il ya des indications qui sont posées on
les professionnels de santé pour un
certain nombre de malades qui se voient
prescrire ces masques celles et ceux qui
ne se voit pas recommander l'utilisation
des masses ne doivent pas en porter je
vous le disais il ya eu un premier
dessin déstockage récent les 17 et 18
mars de 12,3 millions de masques
chirurgicaux et ffp2 qui ont été
dessinées aux quelques vingt mille
pharmacies d'officine cette livraison a
privilégié les départements les plus
tendus elle déterminée aujourd'hui ce
qui fait que un grand nombre de
professionnels de santé peut-être pas
exhaustifs encore mais nous allons
compléter au fur et à mesure un grand
nombre de professionnels de santé ont pu
depuis deux jours à les voir leurs
officines pour prendre des masques avec
une logique de rationnement qui a été
présenté à chaque syndicat à chaque
corporation et j'ajoute part dans ce
président qui vit à 17 millions de
masques qui ont également été livrés
depuis hier soir
aujourd'hui et demain à l'ensemble des
hôpitaux des grosses des groupement
hospitalier de territoire des ehpad et
des organismes de transports sanitaires
de notre pays ce qui fait au total près
de 30 millions de masques qui ont été
déstocker et livrés depuis maintenant
trois jours merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur le président
philippe vigier pour le groupe liberté
et territoires merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres une
crise ça nous a très gras chacun l'a dit
crise qui exigent de chacun d'être à la
hauteur
c'est le premier ministre monsieur mila
santé je vais vous dire notre soutien
multinationales tôt rendez-vous nous
sommes là il vous dira aussi que nous
approuvons l'état d'urgence sanitaire
vous avez rappelé monsieur le premier
ministre que les gestes qui sauvent
justes qui protègent commencé à être
connu et il faut l'adhésion des français
de façon encore plus large
il faut l'adhésion au confinement parce
que quand on voit ce qui se passe en
chine
on sait très bien que pour la première
fois il ya plus de nouveaux cas parce
qu'ils ont observé un confinement très
strictes il faut aussi que ce
confinement soit accompagner
psychologiquement parce qu'on sait
qu'ils génèrent de l'anxiété que génère
souvent des scènes de panique qu'on a pu
voir des famines et là il ya les médias
me semble t'il qui peuvent être d'un
soutien considérable pour accompagner ce
confinement
il faut aussi ça a été dit à l'instant
par olivier verront que je salue sur les
masques rassuré par exemple dans les ca
des soins infirmiers à domicile ils ne
sont pas sur les listes prioritaires
on doit leur donner la confiance dans le
fait que dans les prochaines semaines
ils pourront continuer de se protéger
les biologistes ne sont pas non plus
monsieur le premier ministre il faut
vraiment que ce nombre de masques de
protection au sens large du terme soit
un élément de confiance du peuple
français qui comprennent que vous faites
tous nous savons vous faites tout mais
il faut le dire il expliqué et garantir
ces flux de manière ce que l'on protège
ceux qui sauvent et la communauté
médicale est exemplaire généreuse
professionnels enfin monsieur le premier
ministre les semis de la santé nous
avons décidé hier dans mon département
d'eure-et-loir de montées descentes
qu'ovide je m'explique les hôpitaux
commencent à être sûr changé avec le
soutien des maires nous allons ouvrir
des salles municipales ou avec du
personnel médical avec des infirmières
nous allons accueillir les patients pour
faire entre guillemets du triage des
patients prendre en charge ce qui
nécessite une prise en charge d'extrême
urgence et faire en sorte que ceux qui
sont pas atteints de symptômes on puisse
naturellement les suivre à distance
il faut soutenir cette initiative parce
que le pic devant nous je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
président bédié le ministre des
solidarités de la santé pendant que vous
posiez votre question m'a fait passer un
petit mot pour me confirmer que les
services des dix leçons à domicile et
être dans la liste qui était prévu pour
être destinataire des masques ça répond
à la question je pense que nous aurons
probablement des questionnements sur sql
le nombre de masques qui leur est
affecté suffisant je peux parfaitement
je peux parfaitement l'entendre mais je
tenais à répondre
par l'intermédiaire du ministre des
solidarités de la santé que je remercie
à votre question
plusieurs plusieurs choses vous l'avez
dit je pense qu'il faudra toujours le
redire avant même le masque et je ne
parle pas non je ne parle pas ni des
soignants des infirmiers ni de
l'ensemble de la communauté dont j'ai
dit tout à l'heure à madame la
présidente rabot qu'ils étaient ceux
pour qui les masques étaient destinées
mais lorsque on parle de la population
générale
la meilleure façon de lutter contre la
circulation du virus
c'est au fond de respecter les consignes
qui ont été données
le confinement qui n'est pas un
couvre-feu mais qui est un confinement
strict qui consiste à faire en sorte
qu'on ne sortent pas de chez soi qu'on
limite au maximum les contacts et qu'on
puisse se déplacer que pour aller faire
ses courses que pour aller travailler
lorsque l'on peut travailler pour aller
se soigner
bref les cinq cas que les français
commencent à connaître qui permette de
sortir de chez eux
respecter strictement le confinement
respecter strictement les gestes
barrière la meilleure façon d'aider les
soignants pour nous tous qui ne sommes
pas soignants c'est de leur permettre
d'absorber le choc de la meilleure des
façons en limitant la circulation du
virus
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on aime quelqu'un il
faut éviter d'aller le serrer dans ses
bras
mais c'est contre intuitif et c'est
pénible mais vous avez raison de dire
que les conséquences psychologiques la
façon dont nous allons vivre être
extrêmement perturbante mais c'est ce
qu'il faut faire aujourd'hui quand on a
envie d'aider les soignants ont peu et
c'est un geste assez remarquable les
applaudir à 20 heures le soir sur son
balcon
on peut aussi se dire que la meilleure
façon de les aider c'est de respecter
ces gestes barrières et ce confinement
mais c'est tout aussi important moins
spectaculaire peut-être mais encore plus
important sur non je ne les oppose pas
mais sa présence est au moins aussi
important ne les oppose absolument pas
pour le reste monsieur le président
vigier vous évoquez un certain nombre
d'initiatives
j'aurais tendance à vous répondre que
dans ces périodes de crise
nous allons voir ce que l'humanité a de
plus beau et aussi peut-être ce qu'est
la plus sombre
j'évoquais tout à l'heure avec madame la
présidente rabot ceux qui vont vouloir
trafic et sur des ressources rares comme
les masques c'est évidemment ce qu'il ya
de plus sombre et il ya peut-être encore
plus sombre dans l'âme humaine mais mais
nous allons voir aussi des initiatives
absolument admirable de solidarité
d'intelligence d'engagement et il faut
que ces initiatives puisse prospérer il
faut faire attention à ce que cette
générosité cette solidarité cette
élévation de l'âme soit efficace en tout
cas ne soit pas contre-productif et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je me
permets de répondre à l'initiative que
vous prenez qui doit être c'est ce que
je veux dire bien coordonné ce suis sûr
qu'elle le sera puisque vous l'évoquez
bien coordonnés avec les autorités de
santé locales pour pour être certain de
ne pas placer ensuite les genres dans
une situation plus difficile mais nous
allons devoir tous ensemble renforcer
ses initiatives leur permettre dans des
circonstances particulières c'est vrai
difficile est contrainte de s'épanouir
parce que elles seront nécessaires pour
garder la confiance pour garder l'espoir
pour garder ce lien social qui est
forcément
amoindri dans une période de confinement
j insiste là-dessus parce que je pense
que nos concitoyens sont assez
merveilleux
lorsqu'il se décide à lutter ensemble
dans une cause d'intérêt général
il ya des ressources inouïe
d'intelligence et de générosité
il faut que nous puissions les mobiliser
avec les qualités de civisme pour faire
en sorte de passer cette crise sanitaire
très grave
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole est à madame mathilde le panneau
du groupe france insoumise monsieur le
premier ministre
le moment que traverse notre nation est
grave autant qu'inédit au nom du groupe
de la france en soumises
je veux formuler un hommage appuyé aux
soignants et à toutes les forces
républicaines en première ligne dans
cette lutte contre le virus ainsi que
nos pensées les plus solidaires aux
françaises et français touchés par cette
épidémie historique
nous vous assurons monsieur le premier
ministre de notre disponibilité totale
et du strict respect des consignes
dictées par nos autorités sanitaires
mais il ne peut qu'y avoir monsieur le
premier ministre
d'unités dans le pays sans confiance
dans votre action vous avez affirmé lors
du journal télévisé de france 2 que vous
aviez consulter les formations
politiques
quant au maintien du premier tour des
élections municipales vous le savez
comme moi nous n'avons pas été consultés
sur le maintien de ce scrutin
vous avez par ailleurs admis que
l'ancien ministre de la santé madame
busan vous avait alerté dès janvier sur
la catastrophe à venir
pourquoi ne pas nous en avoir informé
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas mises en oeuvre
alors les mesures nécessaires si comme
elle le dit vous saviez pourquoi
sommes-nous en retard dans la production
des masques des gants de protection
ainsi que du gel hydroalcoolique
indispensable à la protection des
soignants et des salariés alors que ces
matériels manquent cruellement dans le
pays
pourquoi n'avons nous pas les tests en
nombre suffisant pour organiser un
dépistage généralisé
afin de permettre une prise en charge
plus rapide et plus efficace comme le
préconise l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
monsieur le premier ministre
la transparence que vous devez aux
français à la représentation nationale
doit être totale nous demandons la
création d'un comité parlementaire de
suivi permanent afin de contrôler votre
action dans l'intérêt de toutes et tous
dans la lutte qui doit à ce jour nous
unir
plus que jamais le contrôle démocratique
du gouvernement importe et doit
s'imposer car la confiance méfiante est
impossible merci madame la députée la
parole de monsieur olivier ferrand
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
matile de panneaux depuis le premier
jour ça a été dit tous les jours il ya
un exercice de transparence qui est
faite devant les français par le biais
d'un ministre du premier ministre du
président du directeur général de la
santé l'histoire de notre pays a été
profondément marquées meurtri par des
crise sanitaire d'ampleur pour
lesquelles la transparence n'a pas
toujours était la valeur cardinale et on
sait ce qu'il en est résulté une perte
de confiance très fort dans l'élite
scientifique dans l'élite politique et
ainsi la question de la transparence est
une question vitale précieuse et tous
les comptes qui doivent être rendus
toutes les enquêtes qui doivent être
faites
le seront en temps voulu vous imaginez
bien que maintenant nous sommes occupés
à aider les soignants à sauver des vies
et nous privilégions tout le temps
disponible avec l'ensemble des services
qui sont mobilisées jour et nuit depuis
des semaines pour pouvoir mener cette
mission mais j'entends le besoin d'aller
plus loin dans la transparence j'étais
moi-même parlementaire et rien ne me
choque dans cette même logique de
transparence madame la députée si nous
n'avions pas eu une ministre de la santé
avertit si nous n'avions pas eu un
gouvernement et un premier ministre
avertit en alerte permanente si je
n'avais pas eu un directeur général de
la santé avertit en alerte permanente
jamais nous n'aurions pu intervenir
comme vous comme nous sommes intervenus
à contamines montjoie en haute savoie
alors même que l'épidémie n'existait pas
en europe alors même que quasiment aucun
pays européen de parlait du coronavirus
comme d'une menace réelle imminente
c'est bien parce que depuis le premier
jour en anticipation
tout a été mis en oeuvre pour pouvoir
intervenir au moment où le virus
pénètreraient sur notre territoire
nous avons pu retarder semaine après
semaine l'arrivée d'une épidémie qui
était inéluctable à terme rien ne
laissait présager
madame panneaux que l'épidémie gouffre
après cette semaine la semaine prochaine
ou la semaine dernière aucun indicateur
aucun consensus scientifique et vous
savez que les consensus nous le
scientifique nous les recherchons et que
les scientifiques nous les consultants
également transparence tous leurs avis
vous sont accessibles comme ils sont
accessibles à l'ensemble des français
croyez vraiment en la transparence comme
une valeur cardinale celle qui nous
guide depuis le début qui nous mobilise
depuis le début et qui nous a permis
d'agir en efficacité
depuis le début merci monsieur le
ministre la parole à monsieur pierre
dharréville pour le groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine
ainsi monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre sous le jour de ce drame
nous redécouvrons peut-être combien la
santé est un bien commun et combien elle
appelle des services publics forts dans
la plénitude de leurs capacités nous
soignants vont faire face ils vont faire
bloc
mais il faut les écouter les aider lever
les entraves suspendre les opérations de
suppression et de réduction pour laisser
l'hôpital s'organiser il faut lui donner
de la trésorerie notamment pour acheter
du matériel
les éloges doivent se traduire autant
que possible par des actes un protocole
particulier pour le suivi des soignants
un plan d'embauché de personnel
ambitieux quand c'est possible notamment
d'agent de service pour assurer le plus
haut niveau d'hygiène qui protège
n'est-il pas temps aujourd'hui de sortir
de la politique de compression et de
dégager de vraies marges par un plfss
rectificatif deuxième question la
distribution au compte gouttes ne
rassure pas sans attendre sans attenter
pardon à la maîtrise des stocks ne
faut-il pas mieux répondre aux demandes
de matériel de gants stériles et non
stérile de masques en faisant confiance
aux soignants ville et hôpital pour leur
utilisation adaptée aux nécessités et
consignes pouvez vous clarifier votre
politique d'approvisionnement quant au
respirateur
n'est-il pas envisageable de mobiliser
des industries qui pourrait être capable
de s'adapter pour en produire
troisième question il existe aujourd'hui
plusieurs outils des savoir-faire
organisé dans un pool au service
une politique publique du médicament il
existe par exemple un laboratoire sans
repreneur à ce jour dans la région
lyonnaise
comment allez vous mobiliser remobiliser
éventuellement réquisitionnés pour
produire les médicaments dont nous avons
besoin et qu'elle contrôle exercé vous
sur les prix pour écarter les potentiels
profiteurs de crise
qu'en est-il par exemple de la marge sur
les tests pour le coc u19
enfin si des réorientations de fonds
sont nécessaires quelles dispositions
avez vous déjà prises pour répondre aux
besoins des chercheurs
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député pierre dharréville
pour la question du financement je
paraphrase ray pardon le président de la
république
quoi qu'il en coûte la question n'est
pas de savoir combien ça va nous coûter
la question c'est de savoir aujourd'hui
comment dépenser comment accompagner la
recherche
comment accompagner les soins vous
n'entendrez jamais le moindre mot en
rapport avec la moindre restriction
budgétaire alors que nous faisons face à
une crise sanitaire sans précédent et
que nos soignants sont mobilisés h24
depuis des semaines pour sauver des vies
c'est même pas une question qui n'a rêvé
on a eu plusieurs fois l'occasion de
débattre des questions budgétaires
ce n'est même pas une question
aujourd'hui vous poser beaucoup de
questions j'ai essayé de vous répondre à
au moins factuellement à quelques-unes
sur la question des respirateurs la
france a passé une commande à publics
pour acheter 1132 respirateur à une
entreprise française
les stocks sont disponibles et nous
avons donc pu récupérer cette quantité
de masques de respirateurs pardon là
dessus ce qui nous permet d'être capable
de monter en charge dans le nombre de
lits de réanimation y compris dans le
cadre de pitau de campagne qu'on peut
être amené à construire comme c'est le
cas de l'hôpital militaire dont la
construction a débuté du côté de
mulhouse pour venir en aide aux hôpitaux
de la région grand est
nous sommes pour la première fois fin
nous avons concédé des buts et je sais
que vous y êtes sensible à une
réquisition total des capacités de
production et des stocks de masques
le produit de matériel de protection
dans notre pays ce qui montre la
détermination et nous avons passé une
commande publique h 24 pour l'ensemble
la totalité des entreprises françaises
qui construisent des masques et qu'ils
sont capables désormais de nous en
produire 8 millions par semaine voilà
encore un chiffre en transparence
sur la question du gel hydroalcoolique
nous avons pris j'ai signé un décret qui
plafonne le prix de vente des solutions
hydro alcooliques pour justement éviter
l'inflation des prix qu'on avait
commencé à constater parfois x 25 du
jour au lendemain dans une officine et
j'ai permis par dérogation
extraordinaire à tous les pharmaciens
qui le peuvent de produire leur propre
gel hydroalcoolique vous voyez la
solidarité chez les entreprises aussi je
pense au groupe lvmh qui produit
désormais du gel hydro alcoolique elle
donne gracieusement aux hôpitaux je
pense à toutes ces entreprises du
textile du papier qui réorientent leur
production vers la fabrication de
masques quant aux médicaments monsieur
le député je le dis ici
s'il ya un médicament qui est important
et qui permet de soigner correctement
les français non seulement nous
procéderons à une production massive
mais nous nous assurons que ses
productions bénéficieront aux patients
français il ya évidemment des enjeux de
solidarité européenne je ne peux pas
tout expliquer ici
surtout que j'étais beaucoup trop long
par donc ce président mais sachez que
encore hier soir j'étais avec les
ministres allemands train de discuter de
des rôles des biotech des entreprises de
biotechnologie dans la production des
traitements indispensables pour sauver
des vies merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur le président
gilles legendre pour le groupe la
république en marche
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
jamais aucun de vos prédécesseurs
n'avait affronté une épreuve similaire à
la crise sanitaire cause de tant de
morts qui frappe la france et le monde
jamais notre pays n'avait subi un arrêt
aussi brutale de son activité aux
conséquences économiques
imprévisible jamais nos concitoyens
n'ont été aussi directement responsables
de leur propre vie pour par des gestes
simples qui sont encore trop nombreux à
refuser d'accomplir ces trois inédits
absolue témoigne de la complexité de
votre tâche mais aussi de la difficulté
de la nôtre pour exercer notre devoir de
contrôle constitutionnel consistant à
contrôler votre gouvernement
aujourd'hui l'action publique est sous
le feu de nombreuses interpellations
autant d'exutoire
à l'anxiété qui habite chacune et chacun
d'entre nous 1 nous sommes nous préparés
assez tôt pour nous défendre contre le
coronavirus 2 notre organisation
administrative et politique est elle
adaptée pour gérer des drame de cette
ampleur
3 notre système de santé public est il à
la hauteur du dévouement des personnels
soignants qui le font fonctionner 3,4 le
la nécessaire confiance entre le
décideurs politiques et les
représentants du monde médical ne pâtit
t-il pas d'une construction trop récente
depuis le début de cette crise nous
sommes tous sensibles à la promesse de
transparence que vous nous avez fait est
que vous n'avez jamais trahi cette
transparence ranvin tout esprit
polémique
il faut s'en réjouir mais elle vous elle
vous permet aujourd'hui monsieur le
premier ministre de nous dire très
simplement
si notre pays a vraiment mis toutes les
chances de son côté pour gagner ce que
le président de la république a nommé la
guerre merci monsieur le président la
parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
président le gendre oui c'est vrai notre
pays confronté à une crise sanitaire
comme il n'en a pas connu depuis
probablement un siècle
il faut d'ailleurs que cette expression
prenne tout son sens notre pays
confronté à une crise sanitaire comme il
n'en a pas connu depuis un siècle mais
il n'ya pas que notre pays c'est vrai en
italie c'est vrai en espagne c'est vrai
royaume uni c'est vrai en allemagne
c'est vrai partout en europe et il est
probable que cela finisse par être vrai
partout dans le monde
notre système de santé est il capable
tel qu'il est construit de faire face à
l'afflux au même moment du nombre de cas
sévères susceptibles de se produire
compte tenu de ce que nous savons de
cette maladie la réponse est non
mais ni le système de français sentais
ni aucun système au monde ne peut faire
face ne pourrait faire face ne pourrait
faire face
à l'afflux massif et simultanée de cas
exigent la mise en réanimation ou
l'accueil dans des services de soins
intensifs
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
partout en europe à des moments qui sont
parfois distincts de quelques jours mais
partout en europe on adopte les mêmes
solution consistant à faire la promotion
des gestes barrières consistant à
augmenter la capacité des établissements
hospitaliers autant que cela est
possible d'accueillir dans de bonnes
conditions les cas sévères consistant
ensuite à placer en confinement après la
fermeture des écoles le plus grand
nombre de la population
quand le circulent quand le virus pardon
commencent à circuler
trop rapidement et il est assez
intéressant de constater que alors même
que les approches nationales au tout
début de la crise sanitaire au plus
variés c'est au fond vers les mêmes
solutions que se tournent tous les
responsables nationaux
aujourd'hui songez monsieur le président
le gendre et je trouve cette information
intéressante que dès la fin du mois de
janvier et dès le début du mois de
février nous avons quand je dis nous
c'est la france le gouvernement français
voulu mobiliser nos homologues européens
les ministres de l'intérieur et les
ministres de la santé pour définir
collectivement des éléments de réponse
coordonnée songez monsieur le président
le gendre que lorsque nous avons milité
pour l'organisation de ces réunions que
ministre des solidarités de la santé
pourrait en témoigner
ils étaient présents beaucoup des
ministres de la santé des états de
l'union européenne
nous on dit mais pourquoi voulez vous
que nous organisions cette réunion il
n'y a aucun cas chez nous il n'y a pas
d'urgence
ce que je vous dis monsieur le président
le gendre est vrai nous avions très tôt
conscience de ce que l'épidémie
inéluctable aurait des conséquences
massive
c'est vrai nous avons essayé de
coordonner les actions et pourtant
certains
donner le sentiment de ne pas avoir
saisi aujourd'hui au moment où je vous
parle tout le monde y compris le
royaume-uni qui était parti sur une
stratégie un peu différente en vient à
la nécessité progressive de confiner
avec ses mots avec les caractéristiques
propres à chaque pays j'ai écouté la
chancelière merkel hier soir qui parle
dans son pays avec son histoire et qui
n'a pas voulu imposer le confinement
mais qui a recommandé très vivement à
ses concitoyens de rester chez eux
c'est à dire qu'ils mettent en place des
réponses qui sont comparables à celles
que nous voulons et nous avons mises en
place autrement dit l'ensemble des pays
qui sont confrontés à cette crise
sanitaire ont compris qu'il fallait à la
fois
confiné multiplié les gestes barrière
augmenter les capes d'accueil dans les
hôpitaux mobilisé la totalité du système
pour faire en sorte de lisser au maximum
l'apparition du pic épidémique c'est ce
que nous faisons de façon résolue en
pensant plus fragiles en accompagnant
dans toute la mesure du possible
ceux qui sont en première ligne en
mobilisant les énergies sur le
territoire national je reprends au bond
la question posée par pierre dharréville
sur les respirateurs en faisant en sorte
que l'industrie nationale qui doit
continuer à fonctionner je le dis je le
répète qui doit continuer à fonctionner
puisse nous aider à équiper monsieur le
président le gendre l'ensemble de ceux
qui doivent l'être
c'est l'enjeu que nous avons relevé
c'est un enjeu très lourd très lourd
très lourd et c'est une responsabilité
considérable qui ne pèse pas simplement
sur les épaules du chef du gouvernement
ou des membres du gouvernement qui
repose sur tout ce qui parle à nos
concitoyens surtout ceux qui agissent au
service de nos concitoyens dans ce
combat fort heureusement personne n'est
seul merci monsieur le premier ministre
la parole est à valable emmanuel ménard
députés dans un scrutin
merci monsieur le président
ma question ou plutôt mes questions
concernent plusieurs ministres gelé
poserait donc au premier d'entre eux une
question d'ordre sanitaire d'abord dans
l'ouest hérault nous sommes nous aussi
confrontés à une pénurie sévère de
masques et de gels hydro alcooliques à
béziers nous avons été interpellés entre
autres par les infirmiers libéraux
la mairie a réquisitionné les gels qui
restait des opérations de vote du
dimanche 15 mars pour les leur remettre
mais ce ne sera pas suffisant
les livraisons annoncées par le
président de la république ne sont
toujours pas arrivés
les pharmacies locales ne recevant les
boîtes de masques qu'au compte-gouttes
pourquoi un tel retard
nous avons besoin d'une explication une
question d'ordre sécuritaire ensuite
depuis que le confinement est entré en
vigueur les forces de police constate
son efficacité plus que mitigé
muni d'une attestation sur l'honneur
vous pouvez sortir dix fois par jour de
votre domicile sous prétexte d'aller
vous approvisionnez si les forces de
police et de gendarmerie contrôler ses
déplacements
elles ne peuvent pas être partout hier à
béziers la police municipale a procédé à
pas moins de 300 contrôles et 50 procès
verbaux rien que pour la journée d'hier
quelles nouvelles mesures comptez vous
prendre pour y remédier un couvre feu
est il envisageait pour simplifier la
tâche des forces de l'ordre cela me
semble aujourd'hui une réponse
essentielle une question concernant les
collectivités territoriales les mesures
de chômage partiel annoncées par le
gouvernement ne s'applique qu'aux privés
les contractuels de droit public ne
peuvent pas en bénéficier
peut-on mettre en place une dérogation
afin que les collectivités territoriales
puissent y avoir recours et une question
d'ordre économique
enfin des chefs d'entreprise du
biterrois m'ont alerté sur le fait
qu'ils auraient souhaité actionné leur
assurance perte d'exploitation pour
faire face à cette crise sans précédent
or la quasi totalité des contrats exclu
l'événement épidémique
quelle solution le gouvernement peut-il
et peut-il proposer pour y remédier et
je vous remercie
merci madame la députée la parole est à
monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé oui madame la
députée vous avez posé beaucoup de
questions en deux minutes je ne pourrais
pas répondre à tout pardonner pardonnez
moi
les informations qui vous intéresseront
peut-être en particulier sur l'occitanie
d'abord vous dire que conformément à ce
qui a été annoncé par le président la
république
les masques ont été livrés aux médecins
et infirmiers libéraux d'un territoire
de cette année le 18 mars
nous sommes aujourd'hui 19 les masques
sont donc arrivés hier vous dire que ça
que ça suffise pas par rapport aux
besoins qui sont importants en fait tous
relèvent de la doctrine d'emploi des
masques et du rationnement des masques
qui a été et du rationnel d'utilisation
ce qu'on rationnelle de résilience
d'utilisation de ces masques qui a été
expliqué aux différents acteurs de la
santé tant aux hommes tant dans le
domaine des médecins libéraux que des
infirmières que des kinés que des
pharmaciens etc
les choses s'organisent elle met
effectivement en tension une logistique
qui n'est pas habitué à ces questions là
et qui est obligé d'être extrêmement
réactive la réactivité la logistique
elle a permis par exemple toujours dans
votre territoire d'occitanie de livrer
deux établissements de santé en urgence
en ti au titre de réassort le 16 mars
vous savez madame la députée a
montpellier par exemple il a eu quelques
pertes de masques quand je dis pertes
il ya eu des vols de masques et c'est
aussi un des sujets qui déstructure
énormément les systèmes de livraison
d'achalandage des pharmacies et des
hôpitaux
quatorze mille masques quatorze mille
masques indispensable pour protéger les
soignants indispensable pour protéger
les patients ont été volés à l'hôpital
de montpellier volley des masques son
volet tous les jours dans les hôpitaux
ils sont volées parfois jusque dans les
officines pas par les pharmaciens qui en
sont les premières victimes
je le dis il faut un discours de
responsabilité
un discours de responsabilité sur un
usage de ces masses parce que à chaque
fois qu'ils sont volés c'est extrêmement
déstructurant pour toute la filière
d'organisation et de livraison mais
encore une fois saisissant du territoire
que vous citez l'occitanie je le redis
livraison des pharmacies d'officine le
18 mars conformément aux engagements du
président la république et livraison de
réassort d'urgence dans deux
établissements de santé qui étaient en
grand besoin
dès le 16 mars merci monsieur le
ministre la parole et avocat me
christine pires bonne du groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
elles et ils sont en première ligne
elles et ils se sont tous les
professionnels de santé qui
interviennent dans nos hôpitaux nos
cabinets libéraux nos pharmacies nos
ehpad mais aussi à domicile
je veux ici leur rendre hommage dans
leur dévouement est exceptionnel ils
sont au franc est en première ligne car
nous sommes en guerre et pourtant on les
envoie combattre sans protection
il ya deux jours dans un chu les
infirmières et aides soignantes d'un
service de médecine ont dû renoncer au
port du masque motif invoqué
il n'y en a pas assez pour tout le monde
un professeur de médecine de la
salpêtrière à paris nous a indiqué hier
qu'ils avaient des stocks de masques
insuffisant jusqu'à vendredi deux
pharmacies nasir qu effectivement ont
bien été livrés mercredi à hauteur de
500 masques seulement pour
approvisionner médecins infirmières
kinés personnel de pharmacie ce n'est
pas suffisant et dans une semaine ils
seront à nouveau en rupture sans avoir
aucune assurance sur la prochaine
livraison
dans son discours le président de la
république indiqué nous leur devons des
masques du gel
tout le matériel nécessaire et nous y
veillerons mais pour l'instant la
promesse n'est pas tenue
et que dire des pompiers des forces de
l'ordre des caissières des éboueurs tous
ceux au contact de la population sans
masque eu d'aussi comment en sommes nous
arrivés à cette pénurie
il faudra répondre de cela monsieur le
premier ministre quand la crise sera
derrière nous le moment venu à l'aune
des déclarations de madame busan
beaucoup de questions se poseront il
faudra en répondre devant la
représentation nationale mais surtout
devant les soignants et devant les
français mais pour l'heure pouvez-vous
nous garantir que dès demain dans tous
les points du territoire
l'ensemble du personnel soignant qu'il
soit en cabinet en hôpital en ehpad ou
qu'ils interviennent à domicile mais
aussi le personnel des pharmacies les
pompiers les paramédicaux auront les
moyens tant que durera la crise de se
protéger pour nous protéger
question complémentaire allez vous
supprimez le jour de carence pour les
fonctionnaires atteint du code vide 19
je vous remercie
merci la parole et tom je suis olivier
ferrand ministre des solidarités et de
la santé merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée christine
il reste bonne nous aurons qui restent
bonnes collectivement à répondre à la
question qui consiste à savoir ce que la
france dispose depuis dix ans des
capacités de faire face en pratique à
des besoins accrus très dense dans un
cadre épidémique de besoin de protection
jusqu'en 2011 et ensuite jusqu'en 2013
un pirate bonne 2013 pas 2020 2013 c'est
une autre mandature il y a eu jusqu'à un
milliard de masques de stock d'état un
milliard de masques de stock guetta et
puis il a été décidé 2011-2013 madame la
députée que ce milliard de stock d'état
n'était plus indispensable dans les
capacités production mondiale de masques
étaient désormais intense notamment en
asie encore une fois la crise sanitaire
a frappé la chine le premier prix pays
producteur au monde qui a donc exploiter
la totalité de ses stocks et ses
capacités de production la chine que je
remercie plus que hier nous avons eu des
livraisons d'un million de masques en
provenance de chine au titre de la
solidarité et je les remercie pour ce
geste qui l'ont fait envers nous vous
savez un moment donné on leur a tendu la
main quand il avait besoin de masques et
de matériel on a pu entendre quelques
reproches en disant est ce que c'est
bien raisonnable moi je suis très
heureux que nous ayons fait preuve de
solidarité
parce que la solidarité généralement
elles renvoient aussi l'ascenseur est
aujourd'hui que nous avons besoin de
l'ensemble des pays qui sont capables de
nous soutenir
on peut s'enorgueillir de recevoir à
notre tour ce soutien je pourrais vous
parler des innombrables commandes que
nous passons dans le monde entier dans
le monde entier pour avoir du matériel
de protection qui arrive ça progresse il
n'y a aucun enjeu financier derrière
cela parce que ce que je disais mais
c'est d'arriver tout à l'heure dès que
nous pouvons acheter
nous achetons mais il faut que ce soit
des masques sécurisé qui répondent aux
normes de protection et nous en
produisons des quantités dont je parlais
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure vous dire
qu'il ya une doctrine de répartition des
masques je pourrais vous déclinez mais
qui est en toute transparence pour les
médecins de ville les biologistes
médicaux
les infirmiers de ville ce sont 18
masques par semaine et par
professionnelle pour les pharmaciens
d'officine 18 masques par semaine et par
professionnelle pour les masters qui
n'est si masques par semaine pour
pouvoir faire du coût des choix et gérer
les urgences les sages-femmes si masquer
les chirurgiens dentistes ont réussi à
s'organiser j'étais avec le conseil de
l'ordre
ils ont une livraison de masques
sont capables d'assurer toutes les
urgences sur le territoire pendant au
moins six semaines
les services d aide à domicile nous
sommes en train de travailler avec eux
pour voir si nous avons un système plus
simple d'acheminement et d'achalandage
les besoins évoluent très vite ils
évoluent très fort d'un territoire à
l'autre en fonction de la force de la
circulation du virus
il nous faut être réactif de travail ont
été professionnels encore une fois s'il
doit y avoir un jour des polémiques
aucun problème je suis très à l'aise
avec ça et on part à se retrouver et
discuter en transparence la leur
aujourd'hui souvent dans les consciences
leurs ailes et de consacrer la totalité
de nos force collective de notre énergie
à soutenir celles et ceux qui sauvent
des vies tous les jours dans les
hôpitaux riz en médecine david
merci monsieur le ministre nous
poursuivons maintenant notre séance avec
des questions portant sur des thèmes
économiques et sociaux
la parole est à madame annie genevard
pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre la catastrophe
sanitaire que connaît notre pays avec
l'épidémie de coronavirus et les mesures
de confinement ont plongé en quelques
heures la france dans une crise
économique majeure
nous en avons déjà connue celle de 2008
avait fait chuter le pib de deux points
et demi et exiger de l'état un effort de
45 milliards d'euros
mais cette crise est particulièrement
violente elle touche toutes les
entreprises toutes les activités tous
les territoires tous les français
l'inquiétude est à son comble la bpi a
enregistré en quatre jours
douze mille demandes d'intervention dont
la moitié concerne des tpe
l'urgence est de préserver l'emploi et
d'éviter les faillites
il faut aller vite est tapé juste c'est
pourquoi les républicains approuvent les
mesures du gouvernement qui vise à
prévenir les difficultés de trésorerie
et à compenser les pertes d'exploitation
eric woerth avait déposé il ya peu une
proposition de loi en ce sens les
questions affluent à nos permanences
comment accéder au chômage partiel quand
les entreprises ont suspendu leur
activité pour protéger leur personnel et
leurs clients certaines n'y ont pas
droit
n'est-il pas légitime d'accéder au fonds
de solidarité même s'ils en attendent
pas exactement le seuil de 70 % de
baisse de chiffre d'affaires
comment sécuriser les baux commerciaux
si les loyers ne sont pas versées
comment se relèvera ton lorsqu'il faudra
payer les charges différé et rembourser
les prêts tant de questions étant
d'angoua s'exprimer qu'ils appellent des
réponses et sans doute des ajustements
par amendement monsieur le premier
ministre pour n'oublier personne pour
que cette pandémie ne se doublent pas
d'un effondrement économique pour
pouvoir répondre au mieux à toutes ces
questions
êtes vous prêt à étudier avec les
républicains les évolutions qui
s'avérait nécessaire
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
la parole est à madame agnès manière
innée chez secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
genevard merci d'abord de souligner
effectivement la mobilisation collective
sur ces sujets économiques à un moment
où les entreprises et au premier rang
des les tpe sont très inquiètes sur leur
situation et sollicite une aide massive
cette aide massive elle existe elle est
en place elle est inédite
je veux ici rappeler les grands axes de
cette aide massive en premier lieu
effectivement la possibilité d'accéder à
un dispositif d'activité partielle qui
n'a pas eu d'égal dans l'histoire de la
france puisque nous allons jusqu'à 4,5
fois le smic en matière de prise en
charge
l'idée est ici de garder le lien entre
l'entreprise et le salarié de façon à
pouvoir redémarrer
lorsque la crise sera finie et la
ministre du travail qui est juste en
face de moi et qui a monté ce système
peut vous dire que l'entreprise a
jusqu'à 30 jours pour déposer sa demande
que sa prise en compte sera rétroactive
que au surplus toutes les entreprises
quelle que soit leur statut en
bénéficient et je veux bien préciser ce
point en deuxième lieu nous repoussons
les échéances sociales et fiscales
je le précise pour les entreprises qui
sont en situation de trésorerie tendue
du fait du coronavirus il nous est
arrivé d'avoir des demandes de grands
entreprises qui vont très bien il est
évident que ça ne les concerne pas pour
ces entreprises en difficulté c'est
simple comme un coup de fil ou comme un
message un mail ou comme une connexion
sur le site internet et nos directs avec
des numéros et d'essayer les cinémas
sont en appui pour accompagner les
entreprises
je vais également précisé parce que vous
l'avez dit que se passera-t-il si elle
n'arrive pas à payer dans le futur bien
entendu nous prendrons en compte cette
situation c'est ce que nous faisons de
dans la vie normale avec les entreprises
en difficulté lorsque nous discutons
d'échéancier donc un dégrèvement sera
possible je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur bruno myle yens pour le groupe
le modem
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la secrétaire et
agnès pannier rue nager aux côtés des
soignants à qui nous ne rendrons jamais
assez hommage partout en france se
trouvent ceux qui grâce à leur travail
permet à notre pays de continuer de
fonctionner je parlais de tous les
travailleurs qui dans les entreprises et
lorsque les précautions organisations
sanitaires indispensables ont été prises
permettent de continuer à faire tourner
l'économie de notre pays
ce sont tous ceux qui participent à
l'économie de guerre en travaillant dans
l'agroalimentaire ou l'industrie la
logistique ou les transports et au nom
de la représentation nationale je veux
leur rendre hommage
aujourd'hui nous produisons assez pour
nourrir assurer le quotidien des
français il faut continuer ainsi
les français sont confinés auprès de
leurs enfants ou en télétravail mais il
y en a beaucoup qui travaillent dans
chaque entreprise de l'activité continue
les dispositions nécessaires ont été
prises avec beaucoup de rigueur et ses
salariés travaillent pour que la france
continue à vivre de la fourche à la
fourchette dans toutes les usines ou
dirigeants et salariés ont organisé le
travail sans risque sanitaire sur les
chantiers ou dans les collectivités nous
avons aussi beaucoup de héros du
quotidien
il a sur la vie courante des français et
produisent de la richesse pour financer
les mesures de soutien d'aujourd'hui et
la relance de demain dans une guerre et
d'aller soldats et il y à l'arrière ceux
ci doivent savoir qu'ils ont notre
gratitude et que nous comptons sur eux
aussi madame la secrétaire d'état pouvez
vous rassurer la représentation
nationale et les français sur le fait
qu'il n'y aura ni problèmes
d'approvisionnement
pénurie grâce surtout à tous ceux qui
font en sorte que malgré la crise chacun
continue à travailler à chaque fois que
c'est possible et sans risque je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame agnès pannier rina chez
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances monsieur le
député mesdames messieurs président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député milian merci merci
vraiment de mettre le projecteur sur
tous ceux qui en appui de la première
ligne sanitaires continuent à faire
tourner notre pays à faire en sorte que
la production de médicaments la
production d'alimentation
la distribution de ces biens de première
nécessité se poursuit sur l'ensemble du
territoire je vais pas tout citer tous
les tous les secteurs le transport les
déchets l'eau les banques
tous ces services qui sont aujourd'hui
ouverts et qui rendent des services
absolument indispensable à l'ensemble
des français
je n'ai pas cité la logistique il
faudrait le faire et donc je veux
également vous rassurer car l'ensemble
de la filière agroalimentaire de la
production jusqu'à la distribution est
totalement engagée pour assurer la
régularité de l'alimentation des
français régularité dans la production
évidemment et en particulier en se
concentrant sur les biens de première
nécessité en augmentant les productions
et cela se fait avec un travail que nous
menons aussi avec le ministère du
travail pour assurer la protection des
salariés
c'est une nécessité mais nous savons
produire en respectant les règles et les
gestes barrières et y en aménageant les
postes de travail
la deuxième chose c'est en assurant le
transport et la logistique
là aussi nous sommes en train d'adapter
et le secrétaire d'état aux transports
va sortir un décret très prochainement
qui permettra d'adapter le cadre de
travail de façon à assurer le maximum de
sécurité des salariés pour continuer à
livrer et enfin la distribution nous
avons
un point téléphonique quotidien avec
l'ensemble de la filière
là aussi pour nos assurés en levant
toutes les barrières y compris en
assouplissant les conditions de travail
en assouplissant les horaires de façon à
couvrir l'ensemble des sujets pour que
cette distribution soit là pour les
français je vous remercie merci madame
la ministre
la parole est à madame patricia lemoine
pour le groupe u10 agir merci monsieur
le président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'économie et des finances
depuis le début de cette crise votre
ministère est pleinement mobilisée et
notre groupe tient à saluer ici le
travail accompli par vos services
dans un contexte sanitaire totalement
inédit depuis un siècle
vous agissez pour soutenir et protéger
nos entreprises avec un plan d'urgence
sans précédent pour éviter leur faillite
et préserver l'emploi pourtant ces
dispositifs que nous soutiendrons lors
de l'examen du plfr comporte des
incohérences qui ont pour conséquence de
laisser une partie des acteurs de notre
tissu économique
je veux ici parler des indépendants des
commerçants et des artisans
en effet bien qu'il soit naturel que les
grandes surfaces puis s'approvisionner
les français en produits de première
nécessité et d'alimentation nous pouvons
nous interroger sur la pertinence de la
vente d'autres marchandises moins
indispensables tels que les vêtements
les fleurs le bricolage les produits de
loisirs tandis que les petits commerces
proposant ce types de produits sont
contraints à la fermeture
c'est un fait madame la secrétaire
d'état
ces grandes surfaces profite
involontairement peut-être mais bien
directement des pics d'affluence générés
par cette crise sanitaire pour renforcer
leurs profits là où d'autres se meurt
dans tous les territoires nous sommes
alertés par ces indépendants et ses
commerçants qui assiste un peu
impuissant à ce constat ils redoutent a
raison de ne pouvoir survivre
économiquement à cette crise madame la
secrétaire d'état j'ai donc deux
questions quelle mesure pouvez vous nous
proposez afin d'éviter que cette
distorsion de concurrence se poursuivre
d'autant que nous souhaitons aussi vous
alerter sur la nécessité de contrôler
les prix
qui s'envolent notamment à rungis
quelles mesures spécifiquement adaptés à
leur statut
comptez-vous mettre en oeuvre à
l'attention de cette catégorie de
travailleurs privés de leurs revenus
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame agnès tenir une
ag secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie et des finances merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
lemoine je veux d'abord vous rassurer
car les artisans et les commerçants
doivent savoir qu'ils peuvent compter
sur nous ils peuvent compter sur nous
parce que nous avons mis en place un
plan de soutien économique absolument
massif
j'ai cité les mesures de chômage partiel
pour leurs salariés
j'ai cité les mesures de soutien à la
trésorerie
je vais également cité le fonds de
solidarité spécifiquement dédié aux
indépendants qui réalisent moins d'un
million d'euros de chiffre d'affaires et
qui ont du pardon fermer leur commerce
au pan du fait d arrêter ou ceux
relevant d'un certain nombre de secteurs
qui ont perdu plus de 70 % de chiffre
d'affaires depuis le début de la crise
en deuxième lieu
fort heureusement tous les commerçants
ne sont pas fermées et quelle que soit
leur taille par certaines pro certaines
catégories l'alimentaire l'hygiène
pardon ces commerçants continuent à
fonctionner en troisième lieu pour ceux
qui sont fermés
nous mettons en place
c'est c'est fort inapproprié dans le
contexte nous mettons en place par bon
soutien pour qu'ils puissent avoir accès
aux plateformes en ligne pour continuer
à fonctionner en débit je vous propose
de vous interromps que vous puissiez
prendre un verre d'eau je vous donnerai
la parole tout à l'heure en réponse à la
question de notre collègue et je passe
aussitôt la parole à monsieur alexis
corbière
ensuite il sera répondu à la question de
monsieur corbières et madame la ministre
reprendra la parole si vous voulez bien
la parole est donc comme chez alexis
corbière pour le groupe de la france un
sommet merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre le 14 mars
le ministre la santé adressé par arrêté
la longue liste des établissements ne
pouvons plus accueillir du public dans
le même arrêté
il a établi celle des activités qui font
exception et qui sont donc autorisées un
cran au dessus le présent la république
a lancé un appel à la population
j'ai le site si vous voulez nous aider
restez chez vous pourtant le 18 mars la
ministre du travail s'est inquiété d'un
prétendu recours abusif selon elle au
chômage partiel et le ministre de
l'économie a exhorté tous les salariés
des entreprises qui l a qualifié
d'essentiel à se rendre au travail
or jamais dans un arrêté il a été
indiqué ce qu'est une activité
essentielle ces injonctions
contradictoires créer de la confusion
émérite précision dans certaines
entreprises par exemple dans l'industrie
automobile la mobilisation des syndicats
a permis une mise à l'arrêt de
l'activité et ses salariés peuvent
désormais se confiner sans aucun
préjudice porté aux intérêts de la
nation
une question se pose donc ici qui
décident de ce qui est essentiel
non ce sujet ne peut être tranchée
uniquement par une poignée des membres
de l'exécutif
la mobilisation sanitaire doit être une
large mobilisation humaine et sociale
les travailleurs doivent se réunir sur
les lieux de production pour en débattre
dans les meilleures conditions
sanitaires la communauté scientifique
les groupes politiques et surtout les
salariés doivent être associés une fois
défini ce qui est essentiel il faut
garantir la protection des travailleurs
toujours en association avec eux je
pense par exemple à ces éboueurs d'hôtes
us en seine saint denis
mon département qui ont exercé hier
leur droit de retrait car il n'avait ni
masque ni moyen de se laver les mains
correctement
je demande donc monsieur le premier
ministre comment est défini le périmètre
de ce qui est une activité essentielle
accepteriez-vous d'associer les
syndicats les partis la communauté
scientifique et dot à la définition de
ce périmètre
enfin comment comptez vous assurer la
protection de nos héros en blouse
blanche mais aussi en bleu travail ou
gilet fluorescent je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole devant
la muraille elle pénicaud ministre du
travail monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés monsieur le
député alexis corbière
je vous remercie de votre question ça
permet de clarifier l'arrêté de dimanche
interdit certains certaines activités
les bars les restaurants tout le monde
connaît la liste est évidemment
automatiquement tous les salariés de ces
secteurs sont au chômage partiel ce qui
n'est pas interdit est autorisé en
matière de travail et là je voudrais
faire prendre conscience tout le monde
que nous sommes très interdépendants
pour la santé et tous en soutien les
soignants qui sont au front au front de
cette guerre et que derrière à l'arrière
comme on dit en langage de guerre
il faut aussi que les activités contenus
les français ils ont besoin de produits
alimentaires de produits de nettoyage
ils ont besoin d'internet pour l'école à
la maison et pour le télétravail
ils ont besoin d'électricité ils ont
besoin de transport je vais pas faire la
longue liste mais quand vous regardez de
boutons vous il n'ya pas de métier
qu'ils soient inutiles à la nation et
moi je voudrais saluer à mon tour tous
se moquent ciliaire de vie caissière
chauffeur-livreur éboueurs qui
contribuent qui trouve contribuent par
leur travail à l'action de la nation et
au soutien de nos soignants alors après
ça se fait pas à n'importe quelle
condition et là on va se rejoindre il
n'est pas question de mettre en danger
la protection des salariés
la première priorité c'est de
sauvegarder l'emploi c'est pour ça que
nous faisons un plan de chômage partiel
parce massif comme on n'a jamais fait en
france mais ma seconde priorité ex-aequo
c'est la protection des salariés et oui
j'ai appelé ce matin solennellement
toutes les entreprises qui ne l'ont pas
encore fait à réunir
aujourd'hui leur comité social
économique et sa commission santé
sécurité pour discuter les conditions de
protection
la manière dont travaille le travail
doit continuer mais il doit changer on
doit travailler autrement pour assurer
la protection alors oui ce sera
peut-être un travail dégradées ralentit
pas complet avec des équipes qui ne se
croisent pas avec des distances plus
grandes avec un autre organisation des
transports
mais c'est essentiel et j'en appelle à
la responsabilité des employeurs nous
avons un col tous les jours avec les
organisations syndicales et patronales
et je crois que le message aujourd'hui
on discute dans les entreprises pour
organiser le travail en protégeant les
salariés merci madame la ministre
la parole est à mme agnès pannier rina
celle ci voulait compléter ce député la
réponse à notre collègue mme lemoine
oui mais si vous aviez ce qui sait merci
beaucoup monsieur le président je
voulais effectivement après le fonds de
solidarité conclure sur le fait que nous
travaillons avec cédric haut à mettre en
place des plateformes numériques à
disposition des artisans et des
commerçants pour leur permettre de
continuer à travailler mais magasins
fermés c'est à dire à faire des
livraisons et je pense que dans la
restauration par exemple on a des
besoins qui sont en train de monter on
l'a observé en chine on observe en
italie les français sont à laver à la
mise au nez ne vont pas nécessairement
toujours cuisiné et donc nous organisons
cela non seulement pour donner du
chiffre d'affaires aux artisans et leur
permettent de poursuivre leurs activités
mais également pour rendre un service
aux français le tout en protection
puisque nous avons mis en place un guide
de précaution dans les livraisons qui
doit être appliqué que vont impliquer
l'ensemble de ses plateformes pour
garantir à leurs salariés et aux
français le maximum de sécurité
sanitaire je vous remercie merci madame
la ministre
la parole à monsieur fabien roussel pour
le groupe de la gauche démocratique
république monsieur le premier ministre
le monde du travail est en première
ligne
il ya d'abord toutes celles et ceux qui
assument des activités essentielles au
bon fonctionnement de notre pays et nous
pensons bien sûr à tous les soignants
auquel la nation doit exprimer une
infinie reconnaissance
il ya aussi tous les autres les
auxiliaires de vie auprès des personnes
âgées
ce qu'ils vivent au quotidien auprès des
personnes handicapées
les policiers les gendarmes les pompiers
ou encore les personnels pénitentiaires
ils sont ainsi des dizaines de milliers
forcément au contact d'autres personnes
qui font un travail admirable mais qui
ne comprennent pas pourquoi ils ne
peuvent pas faire garder leurs enfants
pourquoi ils n'ont pas de masque de gel
de gand il ya aussi toutes celles et
ceux qui dans le privé comme dans le
public nous permettent de continuer à
vivre du mieux possible que ce soit les
enseignants les fonctionnaires les
caissières les livreurs les postiers
tous sont indispensables mais eux aussi
se sentent oubliés car ils n'ont pas de
protection
il doit faire valoir leur droit de
retrait quand leur direction les met en
danger comme chez amazon ou general
electric à belfort il y a aussi tous ces
travailleurs qui ont peur d'être
licencié interdisez monsieur le premier
ministre les linges les licenciements
dans cette période au moins
et puis il ya ceux qui se demandent
pourquoi ils doivent aller travailler au
péril de leur santé dans des secteurs
non essentiels dans le bâtiment pour
produire des rétroviseurs dans le grand
est où pour fabriquer des paquebots à
saint nazaire ou encore des trains à
valenciennes il y a ceux comme les
travailleurs des ports qui demande à ce
que les activités se concentrent
seulement sur le strict nécessaire sans
règles claires des entreprises non
indispensables continue de tourner il ne
peut pas y avoir d'un côté un
confinement total et de l'autre des
salariés qui prennent les transports
pour aller au travail et se regroupent
dans leur entreprise
monsieur le premier ministre celles et
ceux qui sont au front sont souvent les
mêmes que comptez vous faire pour les
protéger
si monsieur le député la parole est à
madame muriel pénicaud ministre du
travail monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les députés sur le député
fabien roussel permettez-moi d'abord de
souhaiter un prompt rétablissement au
président chassaigne vous avez raison
vous l'avais dit il ya les héros du
quotidien aujourd'hui ce sont de
multiples métiers qui permettent de
continuer à apporter les biens et
services indispensables à la vie
quotidienne de tous les français alors
certains voudraient qu'on fasse une
liste des métiers indispensables ou pas
c'est très compliqué je vais vous donner
un exemple une entreprise de fabrication
de cartons d'emballages qui s'est arrêté
il ya quelques jours
sauf que ses cartons il y en a qui
servent à l'agroalimentaire pour que la
farine arrive aux boulangers il y en a
qui servent à emballer les packs de gel
qui vont arriver dans les hôpitaux est
en fait comme regard de bout en bout
y'a pas beaucoup d'activités qui peuvent
s'arrêter complètement et moi je
m'excuse mais quand une fédération du
bâtiment
ce quelqu'un on avait un journal appelle
ce matin à ce qu arrêter tout le travail
dans toutes les entreprises du bâtiment
comment on va faire s'il n'y a pas de
plombier pour réparer une panne urgente
comment il ya des services qui doivent
être absolument assurer que pour moi la
solution ce n'est pas de définir au
scalpel ce qui est autorisé ce qui n'est
pas autorisé par contre on ne travaille
pas de la même façon et il ya des
solutions
la grande distribution il ya des
enseignes on travaille avec eux tous les
jours et la clé ministre de l'économie
et des finances qui en ont mis en place
des plexiglas pour poser les caissières
du gel des gants il ya des solutions
dans le bâtiment il ya des entreprises
qui ont dit ah oui le problème c'est le
transport toute l'équipe dans la
camionnette et ben on part en trois
voitures on rembourse les frais et sur
le chantier où l'organiste différemment
avec une équipe du matin une équipe de
soir on est toujours à plus de deux
mètres mais on dépanne la personne âgée
qui est seule chez elle et on lui fait
une réparation urgente
donc je crois que la solution c'est pas
blanc ou noir
c'est d'abord je revis qu'on discute
dans toutes les entreprises avec les
syndicats et les salariés
quelles sont les activités qu'il faut
continuer comment surtout on organise le
travail pour protéger les salariés
c'est ainsi que nous vous rendrons à la
fois la vie quotidienne possible pour
les français
nous protégerons les salariés et que
nous saurons repartir avec les
compétences nécessaires demain quand la
crise sera terminée
merci madame la ministre la parole était
madame michel perron pour le groupe la
république est en marche
merci monsieur le président il nous est
pour tous je pense difficile ce matin de
prendre la parole face à la crise
sanitaire à laquelle notre pays doit
faire face mais il est de notre
responsabilité de parlementaires
d'accompagner le gouvernement
je m'exprime aujourd'hui à deux voies en
effet je serai associé à cette prise de
parole mon collègue mikel le gall à côté
de moi avec qui nous oeuvrons depuis
vendredi
pour le groupe la république en marche
en tant que référence sur les
enjeux du coït 19 nous alimentons
notamment nos collègues sur tous les
enjeux dans leur circonscription nous
sommes à la disposition de tous avant
toute autre chose je tiens à saluer tous
les personnels soignants du secteur
public mais aussi du secteur privé qui
donne sans retenue depuis de nombreux
jours
enfin je tiens à témoigner mon plus
grand soutien à nos collègues touchés
directement ou indirectement par la
maladie ma question s'adresse à
gabriella tall secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'éducation nationale
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont annoncé différentes
mesures pour soutenir notre économie et
notamment nos entreprises parmi ces
mesures le gouvernement a prévu un
report de charge un report des échéances
bancaires une suspension des loyers et
des factures ainsi que l'absence d'impôt
ou de cotisations sociales pour les plus
petites d'entre elles
le chômage partiel sera généralisé et
l'état garantir à tous salariés dans
cette situation 80% de son salaire est
100 % s'il est au smic
nos associations sont également
directement impactés par l'épidémie et
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
afin de protéger la population
nous ne devons pas oublier que les
associations représentent 10 % du pib et
un million huit cent mille emplois
elles agissent quotidiennement pour les
personnes les plus vulnérables et sont
au fondement de la solidarité cette
solidarité qui y est dans la période que
nous vivons primordial est nécessaire
monsieur le ministre pouvez vous nous
confirmer que les associations au même
titre que les entreprises seront
également destinataires de ces mesures
merci merci chers collègues la parole de
monsieur gabriel a tall secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la député
michel piron
le premier ministre l'a dit tout à
l'heure dans un moment de crise comme
celui que nous connaissons un certain
nombre de choses ce
révèle et moi ce que je veux ce sur quoi
je veux insister c'est aussi ce qui se
révèle depuis quelques jours maintenant
et 7 ce grand besoin et ce grand
témoignage de solidarité et de liens
qu'expriment les français évidemment à
20h en se rendant à leur fenêtre mais
plus globalement en cherchant comment
ils peuvent aider et comment ils peuvent
être utiles pendant cette crise et pour
cela nous avons besoin des associations
nous avons besoin des associations parce
qu'elles ont un rôle social absolument
majeur et que dans ce contexte le social
l'aide d'urgence aux plus démunis ça
n'est pas du deuxième rideau à côté du
sanitaire c'est au moins aussi important
parce que nous savons que dans une crise
sanitaire comme celle ci les premières
victimes peuvent être celles qui sont
d'habitude les plus vulnérables et les
plus éloignés c'est la raison pour
laquelle avec jean michel blanc car nous
avons réuni les réseaux associatifs pour
faire le point avec eux en début de
semaine il y à un message qu'il faut
faire passer et je vous remercie
vraiment madame la députée paieront pour
votre question c'est que l'ensemble des
mesures qui ont été annoncées en soutien
aux entreprises sont ouvertes aux
associations employeuses en matière de
chômage partiel pour maintenir les
emplois en matière de décalage du
paiement des impôts et des charges en
matière de délais donnés aussi sur le
paiement des loyers les charges et les
clans en matière d'électricité etc
toutes ces mesures là sont ouvertes aux
associations et j'invite les
associations qui se posent des questions
à se rendre sur notre site
association point gouv.fr pour avoir
toutes les informations et tous les
contacts pour faire valoir leurs droits
la deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
des associations qui manquent de bras
aujourd'hui il faut le dire les restos
du coeur un tiers des bénévoles ont plus
de soixante dix ans je parle des
bénévoles réguliers évidemment ces
bénévoles
en ce moment ils sont confinés chez eux
ils ne peuvent pas à sortir faire du
bénévolat parce qu'ils sont les plus à
risque face à l'épidémie il faut donc
mobiliser les français à la demande du
président de la république et du jeu
premier ministre nous allons lancer dans
les heures qui viennent
un appel à la mobilisation des français
pour répondre à cette pénurie de
bénévoles que nous constatons dans un
certain nombre de secteurs absolument
vitaux pour beaucoup de français
une plateforme va être lancée pour
mettre en relation ces associations avec
les français qui le pourront évidemment
je sais que vous serez à
particulièrement mobilisés pour faire
connaître ce dispositif
merci monsieur le ministre
nous allons terminer cette séance avec
une question portant sur le thème de
l'éducation
je sais de la parole à monsieur charles
de courson pour le groupe liberté et
territoires monsieur le ministre les
personnels soignants réquisitionnés ou
non fournissent un effort considérable
24 heures sur 24 et tous les jours pour
faire face à un afflux croissant de
malades et cet effort doit être soutenue
fortement et dans la durée
dans ce cas le gouvernement a décidé de
mettre en place un service de garde pour
permettre à tous les personnels
soignants et plus largement à tous les
fonctionnaires indispensables à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire de faire
garder leurs enfants
pourtant nous constatons dans certains
secteurs de nombreuses difficultés pour
mettre en place un service de garde qui
fonctionne effectivement 24 heures sur
monsieur le ministre pour mieux nous
faire le point devant la représentation
nationale
quant à la mise en oeuvre de ce service
de garde est envisagée ou de prendre des
mesures complémentaires comme par
exemple droit de réquisition de certains
personnels pour rendre effectif ce
service de garde
la parole à monsieur jean michel
blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le député pour cette question
qui permet de faire le point sur ce que
fait l'éducation nationale en ce moment
nous avons deux missions essentielles en
cette période
l'une d'assurer l'enseignement pour les
plus de 12 millions d'élèves à distance
et vous avez les 850 mille professeurs
mobilisés pour cela avec le dispositif
ma classe à la maison mais aussi toute
une série de méthodes pour arriver
jusqu'aux jusqu'aux élèves
nous avons eu quelques difficultés
informatiques lundi mais les choses
s'améliorent au fil du temps et je
voudrais rendre hommage à cette
mobilisation de l'ensemble des
professeurs de france et puis il y à
vous l'avez dit l'accueil des enfants de
soignants et vous l'avez très bien dit
nous devons tous nous touchent les
français et a fortiori nous le service
public être derrière les personnels
soignants pour qu'ils puissent faire ce
qu'ils ont à faire dans la plus grande
quiétude possible quant à la garde de
leurs enfants
c'est pourquoi nous avons mis sur pied
ce service ce service existe dans toute
la france et pour cette raison
que la plupart des écoles et des
collèges sont encore ouverts pour ce que
nous appelons la permanence pédagogique
et là nous accueillons tous les enfants
de soignants à partir du moment où il ya
évidemment la l'attestation de cela nous
avons ainsi accueilli 28 mille élèves
mardi dernier ils étaient quatorze mille
lundi il ya donc une montée en puissance
nous pensons que ça va être entre 30 et
40 mille élèves de manière stable qui
sont accueillis par nos personnels il
n'a pas été nécessaire de faire de
réquisition nous avons eu des
volontaires auquel je tiens à rendre
hommage des professeurs qui se sont
présentés pour pouvoir être là et bien
entendu nous avons aussi le devoir de
leur assurer de bonnes conditions
sanitaires notamment la présence de
savons et de gels hydro alcooliques dans
les écoles la distance de plus de 1
mètre et c'est aussi pour cela que ce
n'est jamais des groupes de plus de 10
élèves
il ya un autre sujet qui était implicite
dans votre question c'est à dire le
mercredi et le week end
et là aussi nous devons évidemment
offrir un service au personnel soignant
pour cela il ya non seulement les
personnels de l'éducation nationale
volontaire mais il ya aussi les
personnels des collectivités locales
nous nous sommes entendus avec les
présidents des que des élus pour pour
cela et puis aussi le monde associatif
auquel on vient de faire référence avec
gabriella talent parce que les
associations sont mobilisées pour cela
pour que sept jours sur sept nous
puissions assurer une garde au service
des personnels soignants pour que leurs
enfants soient gardés je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre vous
souhaitez intervenir chaque collègue sur
le court son oui monsieur le ministre
simplement une petite question
complémentaire c'est bien 24 heures sur
parce que c'est ça aussi le problème des
soignants il sait jour et nuit micro
réponse non c'est sept jours sur sept
mais savait pas 24 heures sur 24 et les
mécanismes de garde de nuit doivent être
probablement différent je ne peux pas
assurer sa pour la nuit dans les écoles
et les collèges
en revanche que ce soit pendant toute la
journée et que ce soit 7 jours sur 7 ça
oui nous le garantissons
merci monsieur le ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement est terminée
mais avant de lever la séance
je tiens à remercier les fonctionnaires
et tous les personnels de l'assemblée
nationale qui se sont investis et
s'investissent pour permettre à nos
travaux de se dérouler je vous remercie
de sortir de manière échelonnée
prochaine séance cet après midi à 15h
projet de loi de finances rectificative
pour 2020 la séance est levée